when the pandemic hit and countries
closed their borders
businesses that rely mainly on tourists
were badly affected
hot air balloon pilot noor atika kyrodin
and her sister
who run a company that organizes
ballooning events
turned to their other passion baking
cookies to supplement their income
we had to downsize by letting go of our
office that we've been in for the past
six years and also we had to let go
our stuff domestic lockdowns closed
international borders
a global recession these factors drag
down output in most economies
but economic recovery has begun in many
asian countries
according to a forecast by the asian
development bank
growth which strengthened in the latter
part of last year
has been driven mostly by exports of
electronics and personal protective
equipment
developing asia which groups 45
countries in asia pacific
is forecast to grow 7.3 this year
rapid economic recovery in the us means
uh stronger uh import demand the us
is you know in for more for many uh
asian economies is
you know one of the top two top three
trading partners
and therefore that will likely provide a
boost to growth
but the outlook for asia-pacific
countries will depend mainly on how the
pandemic unfolds
many countries have started vaccination
programs but any delay in roll out
could prolong the crisis new outbreaks
and subsequent curbs on movement will
disrupt mobility
and economic activity even as economies
recover
countries will be counting the cost of
the pandemic for years to come
school closures disrupted education and
students in developing asia lost
nearly a third of a year's learning on
average
that could substantially reduce future
earnings and productivity
the asian development bank says getting
back on the path to growth
will require a vast amount of government
and private funds
florence louis al jazeera kuala lumpur